c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que je vais prendre les
vacances rien non mais je vais
décompresser je vais surtout lire on va
passer une culture donc je pense que je
vais faire tous d'une valise que deux
livres les libérer
livres et jeux balades et faire des
grandes familles la famille mais
voilà soleil pas enfin je crois que
c'est les vacances à peu tout le monde
enfin peut-être mais je ne suis pas sûr
que c'est cet été je vais passer
beaucoup de temps en famille
je vais répéter mon spectacle qui
courent c'est dans toute la france à
partir du mois de septembre
je vais écrire aussi et voilà mais
beaucoup beaucoup de temps dans le sud
de la france en famille avec les cousins
et cousines tati et à taëz
[Musique]